florida is a state where most people
go to the supermarket to buy their food
but they don't realize that they can
grow
most of their food right at home today
i'm really excited to have pete canaris
on the channel
and he's going to introduce you to 10
different plants that you can grow
that are super abundant and resilient
for the florida climate to help you grow
a large amount of your food at home and
be able to skip
those trips to the grocery store this
doesn't just apply to florida though
semi-tropical climates exist
around the world the caribbean central
and south america
southeast asia parts of africa and parts
of australia just to name some places
are all places where this can be a super
helpful video to you
all right what's up guys what's going on
so pete canaris here with green dreams
and i'm coming at you from tampa florida
i'm about 20 miles north of tampa
and we're growing into some tropical
environment here in 9b and i'm taking
over rob greenfield's channel today so
i'm putting together a video together
for you all on our top 10
food crops to grow into some tropical
environment for self-sufficiency and
these are the top 10 go-to food crops
that are super easy to grow
and something i'll tell you guys is well
you know we focused on plants that
thrive on neglect
that grow with ease most of these crops
are perennial crops and by perennial i
mean
something that doesn't need to be
replanted every year like you would an
annual this is a plant
at one time and typically forget it you
know so perennial crops are crops that
live two or more years
so the first one i want to talk to you
guys about is actually right here behind
me this is just over my left shoulder
this is chaya or tree spinach and you
can see the big giant leaves off of this
tree
and this is a really easy one to get
going or established in your garden
this is one that i tell people about all
the time and the first thing that kind
of scares them about this one is it has
to be cooked so chaya does need to be
cooked for about 10 minutes
there's an off gas of cyanide that comes
off of there you definitely don't want
to use an aluminum pot
but this is a staple crop this is a real
big time staple crop in like central
america
this is a really easy one to propagate
and start so you know if you wanted to
share this one with your friends
you would simply take a cutting like
this stick it in the ground
take off the leaves and it'll start
growing it's really that easy
the leaves from this are actually quite
delicious i find this tree to be really
really
the flavor of the leaves to kind of be
like a hearty
you know they're really filling they go
really well in a soup really well in a
dish
also known as tree spinach this is four
times as nutritious than typical spinach
and it wants to grow here it wants to
grow here through our hot summer
our humidity and our full sun the number
two plant i want to talk to you guys
about that is a must-have for your
garden is sitting here behind me and
this is moringa olafera
this one really likes full sun if you
noticed i had that chaya kind of in a
dappled light understory situation
this one wants to be out in full sun and
i look at this tree as like having a
health food store in your backyard
this one is like 22 protein by weight
68 different antioxidants four times the
calcium of milk
i could go off about all the different
minerals and nutrients
that are inside of this plant this one
is literally
um one of the fastest growing trees we
also have on the farm so commercially
they grow these trees about a foot apart
and they prune off the new growth every
week
most commonly you would dry those leaves
and powder them but you can put this
fresh into a salad
you could put this fresh into a smoothie
you can eat this fresh like this
the tree is also known as the
horseradish tree
and that's because the leaves can be a
little bit on the spicy side i prefer
this as a supplement
i prefer this in a smoothie i find it to
be a little bit on the strong side but
it grows so well
it is so nutritious like the powder from
this tree
goes for 30 40. i remember when it was
60 dollars a pound so
super nutritious my number three muscro
cop for florida
um would be what rob would like to call
yucca or cassava or maniac
we got a lot of comments on that one
from the videos we did together
this is a must-grow crop super easy to
grow crop down here in florida and this
is um
you know what they would make tapioca
pudding from so cassava is a root crop
and it's really easy to get started in
the garden it's one that you literally
just like i showed you on the chaya
you take a cutting of so probably
something a little bit older than this
you want like three notes above three
nodes below the soil you just stick this
guy in the ground it'll grow
usually cassava's about an eight to nine
month crop you'll get a root crop off of
that and
i just did a specific video on cassava
on cooking it
on harvesting it on growing select
varieties with my good friend josh from
heart
so if you want more detail on that head
over to my channel and you'll see a
little bit more specific
stuff with josh how they cook it how
they prepare it
i had cassava bread while i was there i
mean there's many different ways to eat
this
cassava must grow it the third crop i
want to talk to you about today are
sweet potatoes and
you know many people when you think
sweet potato you think that typical just
orange sweet potato but there's
hundreds of heirloom varieties of sweet
potato there are white sweet potatoes
purple sweet potatoes
regular typical orange sweet potatoes
but what a lot of people don't know is
you can eat the leaves and the roots of
a sweet potato so
sweet potatoes just happen to be one of
the most nutritious crops in the world
for that reason
so what i really like to do is to pull
all of these young leaves off of here
and you can see i mean this isn't a very
good example of a sweet potato patch
i just have a couple of slips that we
planted here maybe a month ago that are
starting to take over
but i could tell you is if i came back
in this area in just a few weeks
this would be a solid sea of green so
the leaves are just kind of starting to
fill in
and you would start sweet potatoes by
buying just organic sweet potatoes at
the grocery store
sticking them in some soil letting the
sprouts come off and you break those off
and that's what would be called a slip
so if you don't start it from a potato
you actually order slips in spring from
one of these sweet potato type companies
and like i said there's many different
varieties and types and not only do you
get this
awesome potato at the end of season
which is really fun to dig up to pull
out of the ground
you know you don't have to eat them
right away they can last six to nine
months inside of your house
but during that entire time you can eat
the leaves off of the sweet potatoes so
sweet potatoes are super exciting for me
because i i personally
really love the flavor of the greens
they're great sauteed with just a little
salt and pepper on them
make a great dish side and then you get
potatoes at the end of the season
so digging up sweet potatoes is probably
one of my favorite events out here on
the farm
my number five favorite perennial
vegetable to grow down here in the food
forest
is siso spinach or miami spinach and
this one makes a really nice ground
cover
can take full sun or dappled light you
can see i accidentally
ripped a little bit of that root out i
could stick it back in the ground it'll
easily grow
this is one that doesn't need to be
cooked it can be eaten raw
it really has a nice texture to it it's
not too slimy
goes really great in a salad goes really
great just eating it fresh or any type
of dish
this is a great perennial vegetable that
i planted one time
that's been here for multiple years
that's here all summer long if i want to
come outside and have something to add
as a green on a salad
or to a plate so siso spinach is
definitely worth growing if you're in a
subtropical environment
we've got like one or two varieties of
this one it is just great you know like
i said that
has a nice crunch to the leaf it's not
too slimy
makes a great perennial vegetable to add
to your landscape so
number five my number six must-have for
sustainable garden in florida
is definitely going to be katuk katuk is
an awesome perennial vegetable
super high in protein very similar to
like moringa where it's like 20
protein um and it tastes delicious it
literally tastes like raw peas so
it's one that really has a nice flavor
raw kids like everybody i've given this
one to they're like wow that tasted
pretty good
i have a variegated variety and a green
variety they both thrive on neglect
these plants never get watered these
plants never get fertilized
there is no irrigation here and they
live and they thrive on neglect all year
long so
with a lot of these perennial vegetables
the sisu spinach the moringa
the katuk that young growth that new
growth that's coming off the top is
going to be the most tender the softest
so
as i work my way down the plant like
these bottom leaves
these are going to be a little tougher
they're still great to eat they can
still go in a dish
probably better in a cooked dish because
they'll break them down a little bit
but for eating fresh i find the raw tips
are always best so
katuk grow it my number six fruit crop
to grow here in florida which probably
would not be
typically looked at as like a vegetable
um is papaya
so papaya was something that i really
enjoyed with spending time with rob it's
something he commonly made in his dishes
i think my favorite was his uh
thai coconut curry with the papaya in it
but i personally love green papaya i
think it's great as a vegetable
i love papaya salad at a thai restaurant
and i love the flavor of a good
ripe papaya as a fruit so you know
papayas don't have to be eaten ripe they
can be eaten green like a vegetable
you know we're starting to get some
little papayas here and you can get
these
while they get larger and they're green
or you can wait until they get ripe and
actually eat it as a
vegetable this one doesn't have a lot of
fruit on it right now the other ones i
have are tall and i need to cut them
back you can cut your papayas back every
couple of years
one of my mentors the guy i feature a
lot on my channel is jim kovaleski
he's got a papaya tree in his front yard
that's like five or six years old so
these trees can last a while
they can be perennial they could die
back if you're further north but you
could start them in your greenhouse and
get them outside you know
right after that last frost and
potentially get a green fruit in like
six months so
papayas are definitely worth growing you
know find a good one grow the seed out
really easy to get started
highly suggest growing it number seven
i've been really busy the last couple of
weeks with the nursery business and all
of my plants out in the ground for these
last three have been cut down for
cuttings and propagation
so i'm over here in the nursery where i
have some better examples and the one i
want to talk to you about now
is edible leaf hibiscus and that's this
big leaf plant right here behind me
and this can be used as a wrap you can
eat in raw
chopped up in a salad be used as a green
and this is one that might be a little
bit more on the muse analogous side
tight
you know maybe slightly slimy some would
say that's really good that's good for
lining our insides
this variety is actually less slimy than
the variety i have over here on this
side
this one definitely has a little bit
more of the muce analogous to it i have
a couple different varieties
i have a skinny leaf variety i have this
fat leaf variety
and there's a couple of different common
names for this one i really like to just
call it
lettuce leaf hibiscus i really like this
one as a wrap so you know you wanted a
green wrap something that's gluten free
you can grow this for your wrap the
number nine must-have for the
sustainable garden in florida
this is one that the kids really like
cranberry hibiscus the leaves are
beautiful
nice deep red some people call that like
a mahogany
and these are sweet they're sour they're
delicious just raw they go nice in a
salad you can chop them up
my favorite thing to do is like if i'm
making a sandwich or i'm packing
something for the day
i'm gonna be on the road i come out and
i get a handful of fresh leaves
and just like i talked about with the
katuk you know the younger leaves
the fresh growth like so this is a
really fresh red one
and you can see this is an older leaf
you can see a color
difference you see how that one's pale
that one's dark red
so the younger growth is always going to
be the most tender and the sweetest
nothing wrong with gold growth it's just
not going to be the best
flavor-wise so cranberry hibiscus is not
only just a stunner in the landscape
it's a pretty looking plant
has a really nice edible factor and i
guarantee if you give it to one of the
kids they're going to enjoy it too so
this one's definitely been perennial
here it will set flowers all hibiscuses
have edible flowers so you can eat the
flour on this
but after it's done setting the flour
it's going to set seed that you could
save to replant if you're in a more
northern type climate so
cranberry hibiscus is definitely another
must-have i think if you're
in gardening down here in florida and
you don't have it this is one to add to
your system
last but not least must-have perennial
for sustainable garden down here in
florida
um or in any type of sub-tropical
climate would be okinawan spinach and
this is one that we've been propagating
really hard the last few weeks
this is also one that the squirrels like
here that i have a hard time keeping
going in the beds
but i really like the flavor of it um
it's really nice to eat raw it's nice to
eat cooked it's nice to put in a dish
and it's very similar to the longevity
spinach which is right here behind me
but i think the longevity spinach is um
a little bit stronger a little bit more
of like a medicine
um the squirrels don't like it as much
so it definitely grows here a lot better
i've noticed that you know we plant
these two for clients all the time
longevity spinach
okinawan spinach and the okinawan's a
little prettier it's got some purplish
red to the underside of the leaves
um it's hit or miss sometimes the
okanagan does better on your site
sometimes the longevity does better on
your site so i would say both of these
are kind of like a tie for number 10
but this one tastes a little better so i
hope you guys enjoyed this video thank
you rob for the opportunity it's been a
blast i cannot wait to work with you
again i cannot wait for your next
challenge
i can't wait to get back to florida so
we can do some fun stuff thank you guys
so much for following and what we like
to do around here
pound dirt i hope that you got a lot of
inspiration
and education out of this time with pete
he is a wealth of knowledge he is an
expert in growing food and he helps a
lot of people to do this both in
person and through his youtube channel
so make sure to subscribe to his channel
the links to follow him are in the
description
and if you got a lot out of this video
make sure to subscribe to this channel
as well where i'll have many more
guests to come as well as videos led by
me
and also share this comment and
like it to spread it out into the world
and get this information out there to
people
who need it but don't know it's there i
love you all very much
and i'll see you again real soon